[Music]
Johann Wolfgang von Goethe enjoyed what
he described as delicious Mosel wine and
author and satirist Quattro Haute ski
also wrote about slowly drinking his way
down the river the Mosul Valley is about
an hour's drive from the city of Trier
here innovative vintners are producing
world-renowned premium Riesling wines
black macaws Mali tore his vino take is
deliberately bare so nothing distracts
attention from the wines Marco's took
over his father's wine estate in the
1980s and made it one of the region's
largest but his interest is quality not
quantity
wine connoisseurs from all over the
world appreciate his wines at auctions
the best of them fetch record prices of
up to four thousand euros a bottle many
people don't realize that eighty to a
hundred years ago Riesling wines were
the most expensive wines in the world by
far in the 1920s they're a sling cost
two or three times as much as the most
expensive Bordeaux or Burgundy our aim
and that of other highly successful
wineries is to bring the Mosel back to
where it was a hundred years ago the
Mosel Valley has more steep sloped
vineyards than anywhere else in the
world each location is different and has
its own individual flavors but 90% of
the vineyards here are devoted to one
grape Riesling to get the most intense
flavors the grapes are harvested as late
as possible
the region's slate soils make Mosel
wrestling unique design be fine you see
how fine the slate is here produce is
very fine very mineral rich Riesling
wines with spicy notes what's great
about this slate is that it weathers
always releasing new minerals into the
soil good wines are also made at the
long and sluder wine estates near Trier
along with prize-winning architecture
guests can stay overnight in these
vintner cottages the Italian architect
Matteo tune designed them inspired by
the vintners typical work huts on the
slopes built of local slate and oak
these prize-winning abodes draw guests
from all over the world
the myosin guest appearances on vinyl
most of our guests have never been to
the Mosel River before they don't know
this valley and are only discovering it
now we didn't use to have accommodations
so these are all new guests
some are architecture freaks bicycle
errs hikers and people on pleasure trips
of course Marcos longans primary
business will always remain making good
wines he also plans red wine varieties
like Pinot Noir but Ray sling is his
number one wine Marco's Longin is
typical of the young ambitious vintner
generation on the Mosel a generation
competing to make and market the best
wines
it does image the smaller please link
citation in the image of Mosul Riesling
has been greatly improved in recent
years even young people consider
drinking Riesling from the Mosel very
trendy easting for now Moses
Riesling makes delicious sparkling wine
as well handshake and of course
[Music]
wine was already being produced in the
Mosel River Valley by the ancient Romans
[Music]
these days vintners are harking back to
their old strengths as they look to the
future
[Music]